and would you tell a guy to like like to
move on if she like how long would you
say it like she hasn't slept with you
within that long you gotta go boy
I had this situation recently
um
if she hasn't slept yeah yeah
have they done anything or no
have they done have they done nothing
nothing past making out
nothing pause making out yeah
they say okay let's say you're going on
an average one day a week
right after five weeks you haven't you
haven't gone past kissing after five
weeks nah bounce bro go I'm out because
it's interesting because I'll hear man
like I kind of understand both sides a
little bit yeah what would you say what
would you tell men okay like man yeah um
gosh it's hard because
God it depends on the girl you like it
if it was me I don't kiss it till the
sixth month oh God six no I would tell
them to move on six months
no it's just more like like okay I know
girls that'll make guys hold out because
they don't view them in that way
I think guys don't view them or she
doesn't view it like like she'll sleep
with one guy right away but she'll make
another guy wait because she doesn't
view the one guy in that way like she's
more she's more attracted to the guy
that she slept with straight away yeah
yeah I think she's more physically
attracted yeah but I don't think that's
the one who she values more
because women who I think women who
you tell me what you think I think women
if they're if a guy doesn't have a lot
of qualities that's good for long term
so let's say stable whatever but he's
really attractive she'll sleep with him
because she's like oh well whatever
um
but if he does have a lot of great
qualities long term and she's attracted
to him if she's clever she won't sleep
with him straight away because she knows
that probably is gonna eliminate her as
long term in his eyes
I would say sometimes sometimes but it
kind of It kind of goes bad I hate these
terms I hate it do it do it but I think
a lot of times the girls like views the
one guy as more beta
a level of attraction where a girl will
have and I just think like
I don't know that's the problem is it's
really hard to distinguish and it really
depends on the girl yeah you don't you
know what I'm saying yeah because I
think I've had it like I I've had it
where
it sounds so bad I don't know I'll just
be honest I've had it where like really
attractive girls
have been like some have like just slept
with these straight away
and then they've been girls who
arguably a lot of guys she's attractive
not as attractive but because she really
didn't want to [ __ ] her up she
she didn't sleep with me straight away
because she was like I don't want to
lose the chance of having this guy as a
serious term I don't know that might be
what she told you maybe well I mean I'll
be honest man it happens
well she definitely asked me to be out
her boyfriend or whatever yeah I like
how'd that go for her
uh one of two of them I said no one of
them we were together for two years oh
yeah yeah okay
in relation to like the whole like Alpha
Beta thing it's so funny because
I'm like oh would I rather sleep with
like an alpha on the first date because
I'm like oh I'm really attracted to you
and like you make me feel a certain way
or or would I rather sleep with a beta
because I'm like well I don't see any
longevity or any like Worth or value in
you so I actually really can't decide in
I think you do see value in the beta
just not the same as the alpha oh yeah
yeah so no because you know the Alpha's
not gonna stick around but the beta
probably would yeah so that's that was
like yeah to say no was like the wrong
kind of term but it's like actually like
yeah and my dating life is very that's
I'm very much like [ __ ] there really is
no one-size-fits all because I've been
giving my time and attention to men that
maybe don't really respect me and then I
went on a date with a man that really
did respect me and I was like right I do
recognize that I really want to sleep
with you more than anyone else but
I don't want to sleep with you but then
all my past relationships
I
slept with them on the first day and
they still were like yeah I'm gonna like
commit to you and so it's like oh it's
yeah can I be honest well I think that
might have been and that's no disrespect
to them I don't know
um and I'm only saying this because you
said that in your previous relationships
that your friends were like that they
were punching like you out of their
league
there are a lot of guys who are in
relationships
because that is their only access to
regular sexual intimacy
um and they'll commit to the first guy
that comes along not saying that's not
not saying that was the case or rather
not that they'll commit to the first
girl that comes along but they are more
like they have more of an incentive to
commit to a girl who gives them that
access if that is something that they
don't get on a regular basis does that
make sense yeah no
I'll actually agree with that because I
had one boyfriend that's the one who was
very he was very he slept with a lot of
women he was very in demand but then he
actually was a very toxic awful human
being and treated me really badly so I'm
like in my mind when you were talking I
was like oh here's the exception because
he got a lot of attention but then I'm
like oh but then it's kind of like it it
always enabled him to treat me really
badly and so this is I'm a very big
um point in my life where I've I've got
a self-imposed deadline of April where
I'm gonna stop dating I'm gonna stop
if anything I don't feel like I'm
disrespecting Myself by being casual but
I'm now like I've done that I've had fun
I'm not really benefiting and I don't
feel like men are taking me seriously
because I'm casual and not that I want
them to you know everyone who's like oh
you're not with my girlfriend I'm like
that's cool I don't want to be your
girlfriend but now I'm like oh actually
I think if anything oh this sounds awful
because I hate to be like
low caliber but I'm like oh no like I
know what I bring to the table and I
actually know that that's it casual
aside body count aside I know that I'm
actually quite a high caliber and I
bring a lot to the table but I do have
to be real and be like
maybe my behavior doesn't show men that
and I'm like do you know what come April
I'm entering my hot villain error I'm
gonna make all of the men who did me and
that's because that's what happens is
men that cheated on me or did me wrong
or didn't want to commit to me they all
come back around at some point and they
all drop in my DMs and I'm like this
facts this is like really interesting
facts something I'll probably but I
don't sleep with them but they they
still go so my really really toxic ex we
broke up three years ago he's the one
that told me that he had cancer I
dropped my job my home my friends I I
literally gave I got really unwell
because he was awfully cheating on me
the whole time I really allowed him to
treat me really badly and I'm like you
cheated on me you didn't respect me you
ended things with me why are you still
messaging me three years later when I
know you've got a yell but he knows as
well that I'm sex yeah sex and I'm like
well I think I think from the
relationship that sounds like you've had
he believes that he can still control
you
you answer though don't you
oh you don't no well
so I post a picture on my Instagram of
me in like some lingerie it looked good
I was thirst trapping I was seeking
attention no shame in this game and he
went oh that's my Saturday sorted as in
I'm gonna masturbate over you and I was
like
you you've got a girl this is not
appropriate and then he went I'd love to
see more pictures and I went yeah there
are more but they're not for you and he
was like oh okay and I was like to be
fair yeah I should just ignore it I
should just and so every time I reply I
am giving him a bit of power on I I am
yeah do you think that women have an
expiration date on dating
like do you think there's any urgency to
like find a husband sooner rather than
later
um I I think like I wouldn't like to say
yes but I think so I think yeah even you
got like the whole I don't have more
options now than well they say that men
get better with age and um at some point
too but yeah but they say that that's it
you know men are allowed to be a silver
fox whereas women have to get BOTOX and
dye their hair and again you've got like
the whole biological like boy it's just
like we get we get that attention
immediately so like I remember being
like 15 16 and I was like why is
everyone paying attention to me now you
know braces came off and [ __ ] like and
but like men don't have that like
they're they're like invisible to the
world so it's like a trade-off yeah so
so right now you there's there are
things you've admitted on this show that
you get special favors and stuff because
you're a young 100 yeah right but men
don't get that for the first half of
their lives so like the people will cry
and say it's like not fair but it's like
the most fair thing ever and it's a very
small percentage of men that actually
become Silver Fox it's not the majority
most men don't even get half that level
of advantage that most young attractive
women have and I think well then as a
man gets older it then comes to
um what you can provide and an older man
you're gonna maybe assume you've got
more
finances you've got more XYZ I don't
know I think men I actually don't I find
women a lot more attractive than men
like categorically women are a lot more
attractive today over here oh yes men
are a lot more attractive than men
um but it's as a man gets older you do
just assume like you're probably going
to be more ahead in your career you're
probably going to be so that yourself is
more attractive but it's I think I think
that like man I don't know I'm not
really as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation chin helps and it helps
make what we do possible